un pôle médical de 285 mètres carrés
répartis sur 3 zones c'est la nouvelle
maison de santé du théâtre de trappes
médecins généralistes sages femmes
infirmières ostéopathe psychologue
orthophoniste un projet collectif et un
travail collaboratif dont par nos
rencontres par nos échanges ne fait
voilà de de savoir ce que fait ce que
font les autres et que c'était là on a
une orientation beaucoup plus efficace
ça doit partir des professionnels et les
professionnels à partir du moment où ils
ont un projet que ce soit dans une
maison de santé ou par une coordination
entre eux mais la rs doit être capable
de les accompagner
c'est aussi ça le dialogue entre tous
les professionnels de santé médecins
infirmières ostéopathe sages-femmes
psychologue qui permet une prise en
charge globale des patients et c'est ça
que nous voulons encourager coût total
de cette maison de santé près d'un
million d'euros avec un financement de
l' agence régionale de santé de l'ue rps
hauteur de 350 mille euros une
subvention de la région ile-de-france de
260 milles euros
ça correspond à une volonté de la région
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse est bien de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux et on est ici dans une
ville qui est l'une des plus carencée en
termes de médecins généralistes alors
naturellement il est important de
soutenir ce type de structure et avec
encore une fois un montant très
importante pour la ville de trappes
classé en zone d'intervention
prioritaire par la rs c'est une
opportunité d'augmenter l'offre de soins
sur la commune où cette maison de santé
qui je viens d'apprendre la maintenant
représente 14 praticiens
c'est un pôle essentiel pour notre ville
d'autres pièces vont être aménagés pour
pouvoir accueillir de nouveaux
spécialistes et des internes en médecine
dans cette nouvelle maison de santé